back in 1482 a young man heard that the
region of Milan was looking for an
engineer so he did what job applicants
do he wrote down his skills and his
objectives and how they related to the
role in what is thought to be the first
resume ever created that young man was
Leonardo
DaVinci you see Da Vinci in his resume
never put anything down about his past
achievements for context Da Vinci was
one of the most talented people to ever
walk on the face of the planet
right he was the father of architecture
and paleontology an expert botanist
astronomer and cartographer the guy that
painted the Mona Lisa yet if you took a
look at his resume you would never guess
that he was capable of achieving any of
those things if resumés fail failed to
capture the genius and the potential of
someone like Da Vinci why do we think
that it'll work for you and me why will
they work for anyone centuries later why
do resumés play such an important part
in recruiting in our careers despite
little to no evidence that they actually
work in fact since the 1950s they've
become a Mainstay in the job application
process and although we have since put a
man on the moon cracked the Human Genome
created a metaverse and somehow kept up
with all of the Kardashians the
biggest the biggest Innovation when it
comes to resumés has been converting it
from paper to
PDF why are we not questioning this
where we have seen Innovation is with
applicant tracking systems Bots AI that
scan thousands and thousands of resumés
looking for keywords that match the job
description these Bots are used by near
nearly all Fortune 500 companies so
although most of the time you're
preparing your resume for it to be
reviewed by another human being they
often get rejected by AI before it even
reaches a person if this is all news to
you and you're looking for a job then
you're playing the job search game and
you don't know the rules hardly anyone
does and the problem there is that AI
still has a long way to go and machine
learning is nowhere near to making
predictions on candidate success I've
been working in HR now for more than a
decade during this time I've reviewed
thousands of resumés and made many
countless hiring decisions which by
default makes me the resume doctor for
everyone that knows me you see whenever
whenever a friend a friend's friend
their husband their wives their kids
their friends are looking for a job I'm
the first person they call when they
need help with their
resume irrespective of where they are in
their careers there's all this
insecurity and anxiet xiety when it
comes to their resume why do people get
so nervous about something so silly as
updating a resume we've all been there
up late at night trying to apply for
that dream role obsessing over each
bullet point and detail as if if we
spend 20 more minutes on the resume
it'll somehow be perfect it will become
the ideal
resume as if the ideal resume exists it
doesn't it's very subjective
and because of that there's so much
conflicting information depending on who
you ask resume should only be one page
long others say two pages long others
suggest a summary or
objectives others say try and make it
visually pleasing you can't have too
much white space but if you have too
much text it just looks too
busy and then there's all these articles
online that deep dive into the minutia
all the way way to the Absurd when it
comes to resumés arguing about things
like font psychology and how using a
sexy font like Ariel or
calibri will better serve you in your
job search versus a boring one like
Times New
Roman who would have thought that that
would have any correlation with how good
you could do the job and the absurdity
continues hobbies and interests do you
include them or do you leave them out if
you leave them out does it make your
resume look too impersonal if you leave
them in what if your hobbies are
weird what if you enjoy dressing up like
Pokemon characters or collecting Beanie
Babies will that cost you a job during
the entire time as you're spiraling down
this Rabbit Hole you're not questioning
the tool or the process itself you're
questioning yourself is it me am I the
problem the the answer is no resumés are
a terrible metric for assessing who you
are at work and the world of work is
constantly evolving there was a time 10
years into your career you had two to
three jobs at most now it's common for
people to change jobs once every year
and have multiple side hustles too those
student loans are not going to pay for
themselves right a resume doesn't do you
justice if you have a non-traditional
path and a non-traditional path is now
the norm although Corporate America has
made a ton of progress in the way of
equity and inclusion relying on resumés
as a magnet for discriminatory practices
and unconscious bias more specifically
when black and Asian candidates whiten
their names they're more successful in
their job search the same applies to
when women change their name to a man's
but men were not immune to this either
and we often get rejected for roles in
female dominated Fields the pressure to
fit your experience on one piece of
paper for experienced candidates can be
too much and Studies have shown that
candidates as young as their 30s face
agism with resume sourcing so you can
imagine what the experience is like for
someone coming out of retirement don't
believe me try applying for an
entry-level role with an aol.com email
account the great resignation has forced
employers to revisit how they evaluate
treat and reward their employees but
also how they attract new ones
but they're having candidates go through
the same stupid process expecting
different results as in here's the job
description send us your resume let's
take six to 7 Seconds to review it rinse
and repeat and then they wonder why
they're not getting enough candidates so
let's rethink one of the most redundant
benchmarks for entry into any type of
role summarizing a lifetime of
achievements isn't just hard for someone
like Da Vinci it's hard hard for
everyone else during a time where we
celebrate authenticity and creativity
why are we asking for something so
conformative and frankly boring we can
do better resumés not only force you to
lie about your experience they force you
to use all these silly buzzword that you
would never use in the context of a real
conversation like orchestrated or
spearheaded people don't talk like that
who are you Dr Evil
yet if you're honest you're just
increasing your chances of getting
rejected so what can we ask as an
alternative to a resume well we can
conduct Online skills assessments or
request portfolios of work like they
already do in certain industries we can
ask for video testimonial so we can
assess one of the most important skills
in any type of role communication we can
leverage technology to have candidates
team with each each other to solve a
problem so we can assess how they work
with other
people we can put candidates through
simulations or situational assessments
like an intree exercise so we can see
how they act in a specific scenario even
better we can gamify the entire process
to engage candidates this could be an
online quiz or a challenge that would
motivate gold driven professionals heck
we can even invite candidates to our
offices to solve a problem and then
purpose fully slow down the internet
just so we can see how they react Under
Pressure but joking aside the list goes
on and on better leveraging technology
being more creative and having different
options for people to apply will not
only produce a better talent pool it
will also create a a much more Equitable
workplace and I know a lot of people
won't agree with me they'll say mixing
things up costs time and money but
hiring the wrong person has a higher
price almost
30% of their annual salary plus all the
time it took for you to train them
subsequently it's all about building
trust and a culture of belonging if you
ask any CEO about their culture they'll
say it's Unique but to apply to be a
part of it is exactly the same as their
competitors which not only limits their
options they end up competing for the
same type of talent which results in
workplaces that lack diversity if your
culture is inclusive have people choose
how they want to apply so they can
customize their experience and put their
best foot forward
ultimately there are better Alternatives
than the resume and maybe we don't need
to get rid of them completely but do we
need to obsessively rely on them just
for the sake of what you're used to you
don't need to be as talented or gifted
or even have as much free time on your
hands as Da Vinci to learn from him that
you don't need to be defined by your
resume and once employers realize this
then we'll begin creating workplaces
that feel welcoming to candidates even
before they join plus it will give us
enough time to rethink cover letters
because those are really terrible thank
you